watson zoé et corentin qu'ils sont
élèves de 3e et respectivement directeur
général responsable commercial et
directeur technique d'une
mini-entreprise son nom c'est ce pin up
en septembre dernier 15 élèves se
lancent dans la création d'un produit un
repose cuillère intelligent la seconde
c'est cuisine et actuaire opposé et donc
voilà ça s'explique quand caen mais
l'enjeu est bien qu'on puisse reposer la
cuire sans salaire aussi évidemment le
plan de travail
l'idée est là il faut ensuite créé un
prototype ça c'est le job de corentin et
de son équipe grâce à un logiciel qu'ils
ont appris à maîtriser en cours de
technologie
c'était plutôt un objet basique et après
on a voulu le rendre un peu original
valeur ajoutée une cravate une toque que
c'est un recul hier et ça va dans la
cuisine s'est fait en plastique et les
motards donc un plastique alimentaire
qui font pas à la chaleur à très haute
température
un produit une bonne idée c'est bien
mais il faut communiquer et les élèves
ont pensé à tout
la promotion de la speed up passe
évidemment par les réseaux sociaux ils
ont également créé des opérations
spéciales pour la fête des mères pour
diffuser leurs produits
coût de fabrication de l'as poulx 9,1
euros 30 prix de vente 5 euros et 9
euros pour le duo quand la finitude des
marchés à tour et on a bien vu que ça
pouvait servir la plainte personnes non
c'est nous qui demandons du coup on ne
distribue pas énormément partout après
ce qui serait bien pour nous ça serait
le commercialiser dans une grande
surface il ya beaucoup de boulot à faire
mais c'est une expérience vraiment lui
c'était vraiment magique c'est
incroyable affaire
chaque attaque cette invention restera
donc dans la mémoire des jeunes
collégiens de monde et qui sait la
spin-off deviendra peut-être l'objet
fétiche de nos cuisines
[Musique]